Ana: Llegamos a la última taza de esta serie. Después de independencia, café, reforma social, guerra civil, desarrollismo y apertura, aparece una institución que cambia la vida diaria del derecho: la Sala Constitucional.
Mateo: La Sala IV nace en 1989 como sala especializada de la Corte Suprema para ejercer jurisdicción constitucional. Su papel es declarar inconstitucionalidades, resolver conflictos de competencia y proteger derechos fundamentales.
Ana: Pero su rasgo más democrático es el recurso de amparo. Cualquier persona, sin abogado y sin formalidades excesivas, puede reclamar cuando un derecho fundamental es violado o amenazado.
Mateo: Eso modifica la relación entre ciudadano y poder. La Constitución deja de ser un texto solemne que se cita en discursos y se vuelve una herramienta cotidiana: salud, educación, debido proceso, ambiente, igualdad.
Ana: También genera tensiones. La Sala recibe muchísimos amparos, puede ser acusada de activismo judicial y a veces decide asuntos que rozan la política pública.
Mateo: Es el precio de una justicia constitucional accesible. Si se abre la puerta, entra la vida real completa: medicamentos, listas de espera, permisos, sanciones administrativas, discriminaciones, ríos contaminados.
Ana: El artículo 50 es clave: el Estado procurará el mayor bienestar y el más adecuado reparto de la riqueza, y reconoce el derecho a un ambiente sano. Ahí está la fórmula del Estado social de derecho.
Mateo: Esa fórmula sintetiza la serie: propiedad privada y libertad de empresa, pero también deber estatal de protección social; mercado, pero no mercado desnudo; derechos individuales, pero también derechos sociales.
Ana: Y todo eso opera sobre una cultura política particular: legalismo, gradualismo, negociación, confianza electoral, rechazo al militarismo, pero también desconfianza creciente en partidos y clase política.
Mateo: El famoso pacto social costarricense no es un documento. Es una práctica: discutir, negociar, llevar conflictos a instituciones, buscar arreglos antes que rupturas violentas.
Ana: Aunque el arreglo tiene doble filo. Puede evitar choques, pero también crear excepciones, privilegios y soluciones particulares para quien tiene acceso al poder.
Mateo: Lo mismo ocurre con el excepcionalismo costarricense. Hay logros reales: abolición del ejército, estabilidad electoral, indicadores sociales, Constitución vigente. Pero convertir eso en mito puede ocultar desigualdad, corrupción, infraestructura débil y fragmentación política.
Ana: El capítulo de síntesis ordena las corrientes: liberalismo clásico, republicanismo, catolicismo social, comunismo, socialdemocracia, cooperativismo, sindicalismo, solidarismo y Estado social de derecho.
Mateo: Ninguna corriente explica sola a Costa Rica. El liberalismo construyó Estado de derecho; el catolicismo social legitimó intervención social; el comunismo organizó trabajadores; la socialdemocracia consolidó bienestar; el constitucionalismo protegió derechos.
Ana: La tesis más bonita es que la tensión no fue un defecto, sino motor histórico. Libertad y justicia social, individuo y comunidad, mercado y Estado, religión y laicidad práctica.
Mateo: Costa Rica no encontró equilibrio por destino ni por carácter nacional mágico. Lo encontró, cuando lo encontró, mediante conflicto, negociación, derecho e instituciones.
Ana: Y ese equilibrio no está garantizado. Depende de archivos que debemos verificar, instituciones que debemos cuidar, ciudadanía que debe participar y reformas que deben hacerse sin romper lo valioso.
Mateo: Entonces cerramos la serie con una invitación: entender cómo se construyeron estas instituciones para no darlas por sentadas. La historia jurídica de Costa Rica no es museo; es responsabilidad presente.
Ana: Y quizá por eso este café sabe a comienzo, no a final.